and Nora Isa spends his days stitching
Shores but he says making ends meet has
never been more difficult
we're really suffering now we need no
problems and all we want is for the war
to end so that we can feed our families
and nor is one of thousands who were
drawn to here by the Red Sea ports
fishing tourism and Commercial
activities but things started to change
when fighting began in April
before the war things were okay now
everything became difficult I used to
make fifty dollars a day now the
customers don't buy as much as before
and they complain because they can even
pay because they haven't even received
their salaries
was surviving only thanks to Mutual
solidarity within families so the first
thing to do is to increase salaries but
those salaries haven't even been paid
for three months now
an influx of nearly 40 000 people
escaping the fighting in Khartoum has
made a complex situation even more
difficult
has been sent here for the poor and the
victims but it's been sold in the shops
man this hate belongs to the poor who
were first to come here for long
distances they're sleeping in Pavements
you must have compassion for people in
this part of the country it's not the
fear of bombs or flying bullets that
marks their daily life but it's rather
the serious economic battle to feed
their families or pay for basic life
amenities a situation that has always
been difficult but has now been made
worse by the conflict the UN says almost
3 million people in Sudan have been
forced from their homes by the conflict
and along with Millions more are
affected they need humanitarian
assistance Muhammad Al Jazeera